The above is what happened in the pomegranate class,
right? Nothing more, nothing less. I
don't know what you're looking for, but this
is an ordinary drug store. There's
no way he could imitate a spy. Or maybe he hasn't been acting so kind lately.  Let's
change the question.If I could contact anyone outside in a special way, who would it be?
If there's a chance that I'll ask in a way that I don't like, it would be Fumi, the head of the situation.The
reason is that there is a bandage on my left wrist.
It seems that the colored wood pipe that was wrapped around it had its cuffs wrapped in burnt women's clothing.If there was any meaning behind going out of its way to create multiple colored flames, it would
be a code.Honestly, that gentle head of the situation...  It
didn't look like he was doing anything, but that's just
subjective, right? It's an
old big store. He probably ate some honey to see this, and
did some research after he finished.
Reward a good girl.  If you don't give it
to me, I'll refrain from giving it to you.It's okay to give it to someone else.I think I'll
get away with whatever I do because I have a good face.Come to think of it, I'm
such a pervert.I'll
give it to you later.  Do you hate things? You like the
dark, but you can eat them.
If you can't understand [ __ ], kick me in the groin. If you can't understand [ __ ],
kick it, but there's no use in it. Do you live with it
or run away for your dignity
? [Music]